aujourd'hui l'unicef l'organisation des
nations unies qui s'occupe de l'enfance
fête ses cinquante années d'existence et
au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale ses créateurs avaient prévu que
des problèmes seraient résolus en moins
de trois ans aujourd'hui malheureusement
elle est toujours aussi active marie
pierre farkas daniel lévy c'est pour ces
enfants la cli nations unies ont créé
l'unicef 20 millions de petits européens
qui avaient faim en 46 au lendemain de
la guerre il ya 50 ans
drôle d'anniversaire celui d'une
association d'aidé d'urgence prévu pour
durer trois ans et qui depuis un demi
siècle a fait le tour du monde de la
misère infantile 46,96 rôle de
raccourcis l'europe toujours l'unicef
encore du lait des couvertures pour des
enfants démunis de l'ex yougoslavie
rien n'a changé d'hier ont été signés si
on avancer estime est aujourd'hui le
spécialiste on vaccine 80% des enfants
du monde contre six maladies mortelles
c'est déjà un progrès ygm à terme la
chine
il y avait dans les années 50 les
familles les plus grandes
en inde aussi et on avait dit petit et y
aura aucune espèce dans le futur les
galets où nous sommes aujourd'hui la
chine et l'inde ont donné des l'aide
alimentaire dans des territoires des
guerres dans des territoires d'urgence
il y aller mais il faut continuer à pas
abandonner cet espoir stéphane de
mistura n'est pas un diplomate de
l'enfance malheureuse mais un homme de
terrain 26 ans de service 17 missions en
zones d'urgence souvent après la guerre
il n'est jamais content de lui mais
reste fidèle à sa devise on ne fait
jamais assez mais c'est tellement les
coriaces
quand tu donnes quelque chose tu
commences à être un homme et une femme
tu partages tu comprends le champ du
talit il n'a pas le droit de vivre avec
tout le staff dans le monde des millions
surtout des enfants
voilà qui lorient serait manuel et là on
nous dit heures libres à 87 ans il est
toujours en première ligne quand on
parle de sauver l'enfant
il faut que la colère vous pousse à
marcher quels obstacles vous pousse à
agir il faut sasha
s'acharner donner du temps de l'argent
pour que les petits n'ai plus mal plus
peur plus fin c'est normal dit soeur
emmanuelle
car les enfants sont l'avenir du monde